[Several pairs of eyes appear.]
[Maxwell:] Come on.
[Music]
[Maxwell:] Come on, it's only a bird.
[Animals in the woods howl at the children who are exploring.]
[Joe:] What kind of bird is that, Maxwell?
[Maxwell:] That's only a cat.
[Peter:] Hey, I think I see a clearing, let's go.
[Drums roll.]
[Maxwell:] Watch it! My toes! We're almost there.
[The boys continue into the forest.]
We made it.
[Peter:] Forty days of hiking through this jungle. I wish I were home in bed.
[Joe:] Are you sure we're not lost, Maxwell?
[Maxwell:] Impossible, get out the map, Peter.
We started here... and now we're here, I think.
And if my calculations are correct,
today we should reach the fabulous lost civilization of NO-DE-KAY.
[Peter and Joe:] NO-DE-KAY!
[Maxwell:] Let's get going then, before night falls.
[A tree with a snake appears out of nowhere.]
[Peter:] What's that?
[Maxwell:] A crawling vine.
[Peter:] With a head?
[Maxwell:] Sure with a head, didn't you ever hear of a head of lettuce? Well, same thing.
[Peter:] Do you see anything, Maxwell?
[Maxwell:] I see it, I see it, a huge mountain.
[Joe:] What's so special about that?
[Maxwell:] I see the mountain of DE-KAY and alongside it are inscriptions.
It's the land of NO-DE-KAY! Let's go, men.
Wow, what a big mouth!
[Joe:] Big teeth too.
[Peter:] I'm scared Maxwell, you go first.
[Maxwell:] Some adventurers you guys turned out to be.
[Jaw clamps down.]
[Joe:] Now you've done it, Maxwell. Now we're trapped.
[Peter:] I wish I was home in bed.
[All three kids:] Wow! Wow, what teeth!
[Peter:] They must be the people of NO-DE-KAY.
[Maxwell:] Look! Joe, Peter.
[Joe and Peter:] What is it?
[Maxwell:] I don't know, but it's got rubies.
[Peter:] Hieroglyphics. I brought along a dictionary of hieroglyphics.
I think I can translate.
[Maxwell:] If you do, then we may uncover the key to the great civilization of NO-DE-KAY.
[Peter:] Hot, Sot, Money, Pot. Cleaning, it means cleaning.
Gummy, Gub, Rubby, Tub. That's it, it's a toothbrush, and the secret of NO-DE-KAY is brushing your teeth.
[Maxwell and Joe:] Brushing your teeth!?
[Peter:] That's the secret of NO-DE-KAY. Get it?
Let's take it down, fellas.
[Joe:] I'll get it. Hey, it's magic. It's getting smaller.
[Peter:] Now we can use it.
[Joe:] I'll use it.
[Maxwell:] Use it on me.
[Joe:] Some sport.
[Maxwell:] It's my discovery.
[Peter:] It says bakalakawa. Place the side of the brush against the teeth like this.
Boola boola, rotate the bristles in the same direction toward the end of the teeth.
[Joe:] Rotate the bristles in the same direction toward the end of the teeth.
[Peter:] Heebie jeebies. Brush down on the uppers.
[Joe:] Brush down on the uppers.
[Peter:] Jeebie heebie. And up on the lowers.
[Joe:] And up on the lowers.
[Peter:] Chewy gooey. And brush the chewing surfaces.
[Joe:] Brush the chewing surfaces.
[Peter:] Fooey fooey. And brush the inside too.
[Joe:] And brush the inside too.
[A snake appears to the right of the boys.]
[Maxwell:] Ummummurum
[Joe:] What is it, Maxwell?
[Maxwell:] Quick, let's get out of here.
[Joe:] Gee, your teeth are white.
You better lead the way, Maxwell.
[Maxwell:] How do you get out of here?
[Peter:] I wish I were home in bed.
[Maxwell:] Look, the mouth of the cave is open again.
Maybe we can make it.
[Crowd noise.]
[Maxwell:] Hip hip!
[Joe and Peter:] Hooray!
[Music]